more than 1 000 candidates are competing
for 128 seats in parliament but there
are only two main contenders in
lebanon's elections
iran wants its local ally hezbollah to
keep its political power
while saudi arabia wants this country's
main partner is hoping to shift the
balance back in its favor
its allies are calling this election an
existential battle to regain lebanon's
identity and end what they describe as
iran's occupation but they face a strong
enemy
what you are going to see as a
outcome of this election probably is
that you're going to see hezbollah an
ally
forming a very big
parliamentary alliance
while the opposition to hezbollah very
fragmented
forces opposing hezbollah are many but
they are not united divisions among
muslim sunni politicians hasn't helped
their leader sadal haridi's decision to
suspend his involvement in politics and
that of his party left a vacuum that
could be filled by sunnis allied to
hezbollah
27 parliamentary seats are reserved for
the community under lebanon's sectarian
power sharing system
the sunni community has thus far
remained very lukewarm vis-a-vis
elections
and particularly this is not only
because of saddle hariri's actions but
rather because there is no real
alternative and the elephant in the room
hezbollah is not being confronted by
anyone
hezbollah an armed muslim shia party
that's stronger than the state says the
elections are its most important
political battle saudi arabia withdrew
from lebanese politics in recent years
because of hezbollah's dominance and has
shifted its approach its re-engagement
seems to be worrying its opponents party
leader hassan
accuses the country of using money to
secure a victory similar to that
achieved by the sunni muslim-led bloc in
2009.
geopolitical fault lines have long run
through this country and sunday's
election is set against the backdrop of
a wider regional struggle a win by
hezbollah and its allies would cement
lebanon in iran's sphere of influence
the opposition knows it may not win a
majority but it doesn't want the
hezbollah alliance to take two-thirds of
the seats in parliament that would give
it the power to institutionalize a new
sectarian balance of power
senator al-jazeera beirut